elle a multiplié son chiffre d'affaires
par quatre en 2020 une performance
réalisée par air katif cette entreprise
face à la crise sanitaire s'est adapté
en développement des produits destinés à
la crise sanitaire et aux patients
qu'aux vide
[Musique]
cette société implantée à trappes compte
près de 30 collaborateurs elle réalise
en moyenne 1,2 million d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires son projet
relocaliser une partie de son activité
de la chine vers la france et pour en
parler nous sommes avec emmanuel fievet
bonjour autour des colas
[Musique]
vous êtes le cofondateur d re captifs
alors pourquoi avoir choisi de
relocaliser une partie de votre activité
en france alors effectivement on
souhaite relocaliser parce que tout
simplement on sort du mode start up de
notre société va sur sa quatrième année
et dans un premier temps on nous
n'avions pas tout ce dispositif toute
cette cuisine là qui fait des 2800
mètres carrés ça à peine un an ont
fabriqué en chine on chine tout
simplement
et aujourd'hui compte tenu des clients
que l'on en a dans la défense dans le
médical dans le spatial on a décidé de
relocaliser effectivement l'ensemble de
nos travaux pour être à la fois plus
disponibles plus présent avec nos
clients et pour qu'ils puissent voir
toute la fabrication et être plus
réactif a effectivement c'est un peu
plus cher
ya pas de doute pas tellement plus cher
mais on a cette volonté là c'est un show
un véritable choix stratégique a
totalement
le premier choix stratégiques on l'a vu
pendant la période de coheed c'est que
voyez bien quand il ya des problèmes on
n'a pas non produits et à la fin
derrière les produits il ya des clients
donc
ce qui s'est passé pendant la période
des collèges des clients ils ont attendu
leurs produits pendant six mois donc ça
c'est une expérience qu'on n'a pas voulu
renouveler et donc on a pris ce virage
et vous voyez cette pièce là que vous
avez autour de vous après un mois et
demi il y avait personne dedans et donc
on
on a décidé de prendre un par un les
produits d'art captifs et de 6 m voilà
est donc là ici vous avez premier
produit c'est un abri pour piscine et
qui est fabriqué en france
ce c'est un projet qui va être
accompagné en plus dans le cadre du plan
france relance du gouvernement alors
totalement c'est un projet d'envergure
puisque ici nous avons l'ambition sur
une plaine année d'embaucher 39
personnes
donc c'est assez exceptionnel deux ans
en ces temps difficiles et c'est pour ça
qu'on a fait candidature à ce fameux
plan de relance pour leur
industrialisation côté en nautique parce
qu'on a aussi beaucoup de produits pour
l'aviation des produits qui permettent
de faire des gains de productivité et
des gains de compétitivité
[Musique]
et on a rejoint ludovic volet bonjour
bonjour
[Musique]
vous êtes le directeur produits et
process d'air captifs alors est ce que
vous pourriez m'expliquer en quoi
consiste l'activité ici l'activité en
fait ici donc il ya un an on faisait
surtout du prototypage et la plupart de
nos produits étaient fabriqués en chine
donc aujourd'hui on réintroduit
l'ensemble de la fabrication en france
ici à trappes et donc toute la
difficulté tout le tout l'enjeu est de
réintégrer bas tout le tout la
fabrication avec un process qui
permettent d'être productif et de
s'aligner par rapport à notre concurrent
qui est la chine c'est investir dans une
nouvelle machine qui va nous permettre
donc points stratégiques de l'entreprise
c'est à dire que toutes nos pièces qui
sont fabriqués ici sont numérisées et
découpé sur ses tables de découpe
donc il nous en faut une deuxième
aujourd'hui pour répondre à l'ensemble
de l'activité
donc les pièces qui ont été découpés sur
la table viennent ici sur les lignes
d'assemblage soudure principalement dont
convient souder des valves et souder les
boudins hermétique non l'objectif ici
c'est l'étanchéité les pièces qui sont
fabriqués ici donc on a toute la valeur
ajoutée
on peut répondre très rapidement au
prototypage à nos clients et également
sur le service après vente
si jamais il ya un problème en pleine
crise et enfin on va terminer avec la
partie un peu industrie 4.0 on a pu déjà
avec la découpe et au début et là une
machine aussi qui permet d'avoir une
automatisation de la production alors
une automatisation jeu j'aime bien dire
que c'est un peu notre couteau suisse
aujourd'hui
cette machine là en fait nous permet de
faire et de la petite série donc tout
est numérisé et on peut lancer une
production avec un opérateur
hélas comme vous le voyez également ça
nous permet de faire du prototypage
merci vidéo volée merci beaucoup
directeur du process et des produits
chez air captifs